Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Sister Location: Custom Night.
We're gonna be attempting the Golden Freddy Challenge,
also known as 10/20 mode, the ultimate challenge in Sister Location.
Now, I want to say sorry
for the long gap between this and the
last episode. I know it's been a while but
there were things that were out of my
control. I wanted to try it before I left
for the UK, but I didn't have time in
terms of preparing other videos
and going and doing the charity
livestream, and then coming back with
this horrible sickness that has been
with me for about a week now, and then
also doing the twelve days of Christmas.
It's all been a smorgasbord of work and
sickness and I really wanted to try this
before Scott made it easier and Scott
did make it easier by giving more
power during this specific night.
I'm going to be doing this and thankfully,
considering my voice is thrashed, I will
be able to do this without talking and
I'm gonna concentrate at this very hard,
and then afterwards, I'm going to talk to
you guys about my thoughts and
strategies and my thoughts about this
story, because supposedly there's a
hidden cutscene if you beat this mode...
in the game, and I'm very eager to see it
because I have not seen it, I have not
looked up anything else about this game,
I have not looked up any strategies, all
I'm going into it is with my strategies, a
little warm-up on easy mode and that was-
Easy mode - it's super easy - it's
literally, everything's at three, it's
super easy so that's no test, I just wanted
to do that as a flexibility test, uh, and to see
if I remembered all the mechanics, but,
without further ado, I'm going to be
trying Very Hard Mode and let's see how
long it takes.
It is currently... Tuesday, December 20th.
It is now 12:36 PM. I'm gonna
let you know the exact time that I am
done. *claps*
Ready? Here we go.
*muted music and compiled animatronic attacks*
*COUGH*
*it continues*
Hi, it's now day two. Uh, I still feel a little
sick but I feel a little better than I
did yesterday, and I've got the basic
strategy down. I've gotten very close, uh,
I've gotten so close, and I just need to
adjust my strategy about Foxy, because
what I didn't realize is that Foxy
does drain power when he hits the door
so I just need to make sure I watch Foxy
a little more, which requires some minor
adjustment but, uh, if I do that I should
have enough power, no problem, and this should
be in the bag but I just got to make
sure that my reaction times and my
concentration are up, uh, and that's
a struggle right now, but I've almost got it
so, this should be it, this should be good.
Quiet/Sick Mark: Hi guys. I just wanted to do kind of a,
a developer commentary about this because
once again, I was too busy concentrating
to be able to talk while I'm playing and
I apologize because my voice is still
very raspy, I am still sick but I wanted
to kind of s-shift through the chaos here
because if you're watching this and this
is a very sloppy opening anyway so it
seems extra chaotic but to be perfectly
honest, this particular 20/20/20/20 mode
is not that bad. Once you get the rhythm
of it, and once you are able to pay
attention and focus on multiple
different things, it actually turns into
an experience that is not too terribly
complicated because it is predictable,
and when you have predictability, it
becomes easier and easier through
repetition. Now this is difficult because
my reaction times were lower because I was
sick, but I'm not making any excuses
about it. [Right] uh, I-I believe that anyone
would be able to do this if they had enough
focus. So, let me just go from top to
bottom in terms of the enemies that I'm
paying attention to. You may have noticed that I'm
saying 'left' [Left] and 'right' and-and that's
just a reinforcement to know where
Freddy is because when he flips back and
forth, it's easy to lose track of exactly
where he is.
I double-reinforce this [Right] by moving
the camera over to the side that he's on
and then I say it in my brain so I don't
forget, then I say it every time that he
moves so I notice every time,
so then I'm able to respond to his callout
[Left] on whether he's on the left or the
right side. So after that, the second
responsibility is Foxy. You have to pay
attention to Foxy and this is a lot like
Five nights at Freddy's [Right] One; you have to
know where he is or you have to keep the
camera on him so he doesn't leave his
tent, uh, because when he bangs on your door,
much like Five Nights at Freddy's One, he
does drain your power.
Now, not as much as the original game, he only
drains like two to three percent as far
as I know, uh, but it's important to pay
attention to him... and uh, keep track of him
so he doesn't [Right] leave his tent much and
[Right] go [Right] bang on your door a whole lot
through the whole night.
Now, this is [He's right] difficult because the more
you flip up your screen, [Right] the more you have to
risk [Left] looking at Yenndo, and Yenndo is
probably the thing that makes this the
most difficult. If Yenndo wasn't there,
this would be [Left] so much easier. Because,
Yenndo is like a reaction time test: if you
flip the screen down and he's there, you
have to flip the screen back up, [Right] but
there's also a small chance [Right..right]- I believe
probably like a thirty percent chance - that
he's not there and if your finger is
twitchy, [Left] you'll flip the screen back up
and that's what I mean by slop. If you
see me flipping the screen spastically
it's because - like there, right there -
it's because I was stuck in a loop, of
instantly twitching/[Right] it back up until he
appeared and then I was able to break
out of the loop from my own finger.
So, he drains your oxygen, and he does it
quick, [Left] so if you're not instant... on
bringing the screen back up, you're gonna
lose oxygen and then you're not gonna
be able to see anything in the entire
game and then your focus goes off and
this game-or this particular mode is
broken down into three different senses/[Right]:
you have to see to be able to know when
Lolbit and, you know, Bonnet and [Right]
Yenndo is there; you have to be able to
listen to know when Freddy's doing his
thing, when Bidybab's doing his thing,
when Ballora's doing their thing, and you
have to have muscle memory to know where
to put your mouse for the cameras and
for Bonnet's nose. So there's three
different things and if you remove the [Left]
ability to see, [Right] then you kind of, your
whole plan starts to unravel. Not that
it's impossible, but it is guesswork at
that point. Um, but after [Right] that, Yenndo is the
hard one, and then everything else kind
of falls into place. [Left] Bonnet is just like, can
you put your hand on-on her nose,
it's just kind of following her left,
you try to keep your mouse at the same
level/[Left] on the screen every time that you [Right] turn
back, and I think- I think, thankfully, it
defaults after you put the camera down,
the mouse resets position to Bonnet's
nose level, which makes it a lot easier,
and then you just have to [Left] move to the left. Uh, next
up is Ballora, and Ballora's easy, Ballora
and Bidybab kind of fall into the
same category;
you're just listening. Ballora, you're
listening until she gets really close.
Bidybab, you only need to listen for the
metal vent sound that she makes when
she's near your door. When you hear that
crumpling of aluminum metal, [Whoo.] that means
that she's very nearby and you just need
to throw down that door until you hear a
bang, [Left] you got to be careful when you got a
lot of doors down waiting for bangs
until all the bangs clear and then you
can go, and then the next thing that you have
to worry about is in part and [Left] conjoined
with flipping up the screen for Foxy, [Right]
uh, that's the Electrobab and the Minireenas [Right]
that are messing with your
power and your air, so, thankfully, and
this is where the pattern comes in, they
do go in a [Left] pattern. You can get them so they
sync up at the exact same time and then
you can take care of them both at
once and it makes my life a lot easier
because that's one more [Left] variable that I don't have to
watch out for. It combines two things
into just one thing, [Right] so you're
technically only messing with nine
animatronics. After that, everything
starts to fall into place. You know,
you've got Lolbit in the back [Left] and
that's a little more muscle memory to
move over to the LOL keys, uh, [Left] but all this
is like a balance of oxygen. Not so much
power because power wasn't too big of an
issue [Right] because I was able to get through
this with a few percentage left, but
oxygen, being able to see above all else
was the hardest thing and towards the end
here you can see it's getting really
dark, very hard for me to see, and I
suppose you [Left] kind of cheat your way
around that, you could brighten your
monitor really high, you can turn the
gamma up really high on your computer, and
maybe you could kind of get through that
but, nah, I didn't want to do that because
it's seemed [Right] cheap. And so, all in all, this
makes for a very complicated experience,
you have to multitask on a lot of things,
but it's not impossible even though it
seems like it might be. There's just a
lot of moving parts and a lot of things
that you have to pay attention to, and
there goes Foxy, but thankfully, I'm
already at the end of the road here, and
I have officially won it so, thanks for listening.
Freddy: What a party pooper!
HEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEELLLLLLLLLLLLLL
YEEEAAAAHHHH
*to the tune of the shift end music* OWIE, MY VOICE IS HURT
I DID IT, I DID IT
Michael: Father. It's me, Michael.
I did it. I found it. It was right where you said it would be.
They were all there.
They didn't-...recognize me at first, but then... they thought I was you.
*either a stifled laugh or an exhale of relief, you decide*
And I found her.
I-... put her back together, just like you asked me to.
She's free now... but something is wrong with me.
I should be dead... but I'm not.
I've been living in shadows.
There is only one thing left for me to do now.
I'm going to come find you.
I̞͓̯̤̻'̵̜m̬̀ g͙̘̯͕͈͜o͕̘̠̰̰͕i͇͖̼̩̬͞ng̵̭̘̥̲͉ t̶o̪̥̘̘ c҉͓̘̱̠͖̻͎o͏̥̮m̹̪͎͙̯e̟̰̭̬̝̖ f͖͔i̬̳n̸̲̟̰̯̲̗̻d͉̺̱̺̗̜̪ y̵͚̙͓̦͎͕o̦͉̯̪u̜͉.͏̥̞
Mark: Ooooooooh...
Oh, is that the next game?
I don't know. Fazbear's Fright? I have no
idea. Okay, that was an experience. Man, I'm
full of pep! Adrenaline is coursing
through my veins! Okay, so few things about
that, ummm, when... I do think that it is
probably impossible to beat it
beforehand, because the nights
beforehand were 7 minutes and 30
seconds long.
This night is 6 minutes long, each hour
is a minute, and therefore there's a
minute and 30 seconds of extra time that
you would need to do to be able to beat
it in its previous incarnation or at
least that's what I'm assuming it is in
terms of him giving more power, uh, but in
all honesty, I don't think that would
have been possible just because of how
tight the constraints were, I was having
so much problems yesterday is because-, you
have to, to do these 20/20 modes, you have to
focus for like, six to eight minutes
straight, depending on the game, and I
would say this was very hard... but not
like the hardest I've ever done, mostly
because it may seem complicated but
everything in this particular one has a
rhythm. See, I was able to combine the Electrobab
and the Minireena into one, they
were in a set rhythm, they would go off
at exactly the same time, so I was always
able to predict that, and for a long time
I was just letting Foxy go because I
didn't think that Foxy stole power like
in Five Nights at Freddy's One but she
does, so as soon as I accounted for that, I
only needed a few more tries and then I
was able to beat because yesterday, I
realized that towards the later end of
my attempts but I was starting to feel
so sick and I was just like coughing up
a bunch of phlegm and it wasn't good but
today I felt peppier. Not the worst, I
would put it just before the first Five Nights at Freddy's
in terms of difficulty,
all in all, not that bad... kind of boring
compared to the other ones in terms of
just the monotony of it because this one
is very monotonous because it's the same
thing
coming at you again and again and again
and again and you just got do the same thing
over and over, um, but I would say a pretty
good one, not bad at all, and that
cutscene is very interesting because-... he
said 'father'.... and he thought I was you
so, did he...
*sniff* I gotta think about that. I wish I
could watch it again. What I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna watch it again then I'm gonna
come back and get, uh, get more thoughts
about it because I wasn't able to
capture everything but I'll, I'll go look
it up in just a second, be right back.
Alright, so I just watched back the, um,
I just watched back the cutscene and
there's a few interesting things to take
note of it.
Number one, the guy says his name was
Michael, and number two, he's talking to
his father, and number three, he's talking
to him, telling him that he shouldn't be
alive.  Now, at the end of the cutscene it
showed up and showed, probably it showed
the blown-up wreckage of Five Nights at
Freddy's Three after the protagonist lights
the fucker on fire and burns it all down,
and it was revealed at the end of Five
Nights at Freddy's Three that Springtrap
did survive that, so I can only assume
that from this cutscene Michael, Michael Afton, who I'm assuming that is because
his father, they're all British, the person at the
beginning of this game was Mr. Afton,
and I'm assuming that they're all the
Afton family and I'm even assuming
that the daughter who keeps talking to
her father asking to go see Baby and was
eventually killed by Baby was their
daughter and Michael's sister but all
that aside, it showed Michael as
Springtrap surviving the explosion
which we already knew from Five Nights at
Freddy's Three but that V.O., could have
taken place at any time throughout. Now,
there's been some theories saying that
there are two purple guys and- and I
could understand that in terms of like a
father-son duo, there could be two purple
guys in this and just kind of having a
pow-wow of murdering and creating
horrible monstrosities of death and
weird life an-and you can kind of see
it in terms of the timeline, now, correct
me if I'm wrong, I might be wrong about
this timeline but I believe it goes the
oldest is Five Nights at Freddy's Four
which was 1983 or (198)4
in the original Fazbear's Pizzeria,
Fazbear's Fun Time, whatever it was
called, I believe that was the original.
Then, and in that you can see cutscenes
of purple guy not being a murderer but
just generally seeming like an employee,
putting employees in suits of his
horrible creations.
Now, you go to Sister Location where
Michael is sent in by his father to try
to piece together what's left of-... uh,
piece together what's left of his sister and
their daughter and I can't help but be
drawn to the comparison of Ennard to
uh, the...the puppet from Five Nights at
Freddy's Two because the puppet in the
minigames wanted to piece the chil-the dead children back together
to what end I don't know but this
creation, whatever it is, Ennard, somehow
was able to give Michael Afton near-
supernatural powers of living beyond
death when you should not be alive, he
went in Michael's body, transformed him
into literal purple guy and then was
exploded out, now, maybe that happened to
their father, maybe that was already the
case. I don't know. It doesn't seem
possible because everyone in the
neighborhood was very intimidated by
this purple fellow by the name of Michael
Afton and purple guy walking around the
streets, but it's all just very confusing,
you know, and I say comparisons just by
the button, the mask, the three to four
fingers, the spiral leg matching the
spiral pattern
of the puppet, like, and the general
marionette nature of this creation here.
There's a little bit of me in every body,
pulling the strings, that's the only
thing that I could thematically draw
from that and of course, I am not a
master theorist. I know a lot about this
but I don't know everything so, these are the
only the conclusions that I can draw so,
there may be two purple guys. This was
Michael Afton, his father is Mr. Afton,
and it's possible that his sister was
the girl that was killed by Baby and he
was sent on a mission to try to put her
back together because his father created,
literally created life in these machines
and somehow in a perverted way, maybe
this purple guy who got forced into
Springtrap and was haunted by the souls
of dead children was corrupted in a
wrong way, turning life into something
perverted by something that is, by itself,
perverted life in this. It's all a very
complicated story or maybe it's
simplifying. I have no idea. I would love
to see a grand outline of everything
from top to bottom but I feel like we're
not quite there yet, I feel like there
might be one more game going
or maybe not, who honestly, who knows?
but this one, Sister Location, was really
fun. I liked it. It was a welcome change from
everything that I've seen thus far and
it really, really hammered home the
interesting story behind everything and
I like that a lot, and it was a pretty
good challenge in custom night if I-I don't
know if I ranked the difficulty, but I said
Five Nights at Freddy's Two, Five Nights
at Freddy's One, this game, Five nights at Freddy's Four
and then Five Nights at Freddy's Three,
that's what I'd say in terms of
difficulty for the 20/20 modes, but
either way, thank you, everybody, so much
for watching, let me know what you think
down in the comments below and as always,
I will see you in the next video.
BUH BYE!
*outro music*     Subscribe to Markiplier! Every Subscription turns to Exotic Butters! :DDD